[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
al'approche de noël les jeux de société
un peuvent être une idée de cadeau et
justement nous sommes chez exane games
cette société située à guyancourt elle
est spécialisée dans l'édition de jeux
de société avec notamment son
best-seller jurassique world découverte
de cette entreprise juste après ce
sommaire du 7ème numéro du sky est qu en
face à la crise sanitaire la start-up
exode games s'est appuyé sur les ventes
de ses jeux de société déjà développé
découverte aussi de ses best-sellers
pour ce noël 2020
elle fabrique des sacs des sacoches ou
des bagages on voiles de bateaux des
idées de cadeaux conçu par valérie vial
elle est la dirigeante de la voilerie
atelier couture à elancourt enfin focus
sur la collaboration entre m 2e et
airbus cybersécurité sur la sécurisation
d'un système d'éclairage public
intelligent exact games est une start up
créée en 2010 est à montigny le
bretonneux je vous le disais allez
spécialisée dans l'édition de jeux de
société et depuis sa création elle a
multiplié par trois son chiffre
d'affaires
[Musique]
et pour parler de cette réussite nous
sommes avec la dirigeante d'exode game
hélène barral bonjour alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retrouver sous le sapin pour
ce noël 2020 cette année la plus grosse
annonce qu'on a chez exane games et
d'ego bnat nos petits gobelins favoris
notamment le petit gobelins qui était
offert à tous les ans pour noël qu'ils
perdent beaublanc et planning bière pour
les amoureux de parachutisme donc ce
dont sont des jeux déjà développé un
voilà ils sont produisons très très bien
marché cette année et ce sont des choses
qui sont pour les parents pour les
enfants et qui sont assez rapides moins
de 20 minutes 30 minutes si vous êtes un
peu un peu d'habitants mais non le délai
très rapide avec cette année 2001 très
particulière une crise sanitaire comment
vous avez résisté à cette crise les
ventes ont aidés donc les jeux de
société ont été un des succès phare de
cette année plus que les gens étant
confiné ont développé un peu plus leurs
coûts pour les jeux les jeux de société
et du coup les jeux qui était déjà
produit ont beaucoup se sont beaucoup
vendu on fait des ruptures aussi on a dû
reproduire et par contre ce qui a été
plus difficile c'est pour les jeux qui
devait sortir cette année qui ont subi
des retards de production notamment
parce que du coup les conditions ont
fait que certaines usines ont dû fermer
aussi temporairement en chine ou en
europe que on n'a pas tout le monde
disponible dans les locaux à pour
développer constamment le clae trail
peut-être aussi un frein pour développer
et du coup c'est eux qui sont pas sortis
cette année qui sortiront l'année
prochaine qui l'ont pris à peu près
entre six mois
entre trois et six mois de retard de
production et ceux qui sont en
développement également très peu près le
même le même temps de retard alors on
était venu vous voir en début d'année
pour votre produit phare c'est jura 6
couleurs de développer avec universal
comment ça s'est passé par rapport à ce
jeu du coup alors c'est lui qui a eu le
plus de retard parce qu'il l'a
malheureusement il a besoin de trois
entreprises différentes pour être créés
et donc ceux qui font les moules des
figurines l'entreprise qui le fabrique
en chine et le transporteur qui le
transporte
et du coup il l'est il a pris du retard
et ils étaient prêts pour septembre et
aujourd'hui ils sont livrés en premier
trimestre de 2000 21 12 janvier et c'est
lui qui a pris le plus gros retard mais
c'est aussi la plus grosse vente depuis
vous avez multiplié votre chiffre
d'affaires par trois cette année 2020
va-t-elle le plomber un peu cette
croissance alors forcément on a subi un
peu de perte de croissance de perte de
vitesse mais on a dû aussi se serrer les
coudes entre éditeurs donc ça c'est
quelque chose que qui est très très
commun au milieu ludique parce qu'on est
toujours là les uns pour les autres
mais on a décidé de repartir d'encore
plus belles l'année prochaine donc avec
la sortie de deux d'une vingtaine de
jeux l'avantagé au moins d'avoir subi du
routard c'est qu'on a pu se poser
repartir sur de nouvelles bases
alors avant de parler justement de du
futur des prochaines sorties à un mot
sur justement cette collaboration
commence à ces faits concrètement cette
collaboration entre éditeurs ces issues
en fait de jurassic à la base un éditeur
qui m'a contacté en me disant qu'il
aurait bien aimé me apporter son aide
sur le projet parce que il en était fan
et sortir des projets
un ex dessus notamment avec la corde
universal et au fur et à mesure on a
apporté mutuellement notre aide
on a eu un gros investisseur qui a cru
en nous et qui a dit je me joins à l
aventure donc dans la société ge et la
cité jade et on s'est regroupés pour
créer bic et qu'il sera oblet l'année
prochaine et qui du coup a prévu de
faire du transverse et permet d'aider
donc les jeux vidéo les jeux de société
et un peu d'autres surprises de l'année
prochaine et donc justement l'avenir est
plutôt optimiste pour examiner l'avenir
est très optimiste alors malheureusement
peut-être pas forcément pour la marque
exode genk mais plutôt pour lamah beach
parce qu'on a pris du coup a vraiment
émergé pour devenir beach mais l'essence
même de but tchèque 7e et jeff donc ya
pas de petit copain et tout ça ça se
passe à guyancourt sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines merci et le
baram rtm dirigeante de exode games
[Musique]
autre idée de cadeau des accessoires des
sacs des porte monnaie ou encore des
sacoches fabrique à la main à partir de
voiles de bateau
c'est l'activité de valérie vial cet
élan courtoise et maître voilier
découverte de sa société la voilerie
atelier couture dans ma vie
d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle 20 et riviane jeu
sous la dirigeante de la volt vague basé
à elancourt est créée en 2010
[Musique]
je suis maître voilier c'est à dire à se
démettre voyez quand on a 15 ans
d'expérience donc je crée des voiles
quel que soit le bateau après youtube de
l'intérieur du bateau et tous les
accessoires qui compte
où se situe le bateau est peu appris à
tout ce qui est réparation de voile de
kitesurf de porc son voile de char à
voile
tout ce qui est en bord de mer en règle
générale
à force de faire de la couture mais en
voile du coup j'ai bien apprécié ce que
la diversité des coutures et tout ce
qu'on peut faire et du coup j'ai créé ma
société y à pas par envie et puis par
passion
ce noël les produits phares et ben
d'abord je recycle beaucoup donc des
sacs des pochettes des articles pour la
piscine c'est à dire les coussins tout
ce qui est cher longue mais chilienne
les poufs les tabourets ça peut être
beaucoup beaucoup de choses comme ça
[Musique]
le résultat d'un ils sont pas comme
d'habitude donc on verra les résultats
en fin d'année là il ya eu qu un ou deux
marchés de réaliser donc
les finances sont quite bonne cette
année mais c'est pas ce souci on
attendra les prochaines à voilerie
survie à covin encore y'a pas de
problème
[Musique]
et
on poursuit ce sky aequo avec une
collaboration le groupe airbus
cybersécurité la start-up m 2 ième
prévoit de développer ensemble des
solutions pour les jeux olympiques de
en attendant ils ont participé en commun
à un projet baptisé pack lido
l'intégration de systèmes de
cybersécurité dans des objets connectés
c'est la séquence business sky entre le
groupe airbus et la start-up m2 et m
[Musique]
m tout y est
m ou 2 ième est une start up donc qui a
été créée en 2015
l'intégrateur de systèmes haïti et
notamment pour la gestion de l'éclairage
public
[Musique]
le projet pak lido est un projet
d'innovation airbus sas security as
travaillé avec saint quentin en yvelines
ainsi que sept autres
sept autres partenaires au travers d'un
cas d' usage de d'éclairage intelligent
visant à des capacités de contrôle et
les lampadaires à distance on a mis à
disposition notre savoir et notre
système existant on a été à la recherche
d'un partenaire qui connaissait le
fonctionnement des lampadaires
intelligents des systèmes d'éclairage
intelligent pour pouvoir mener cette
expérimentation en réel ça s'est fait
par l'intermédiaire de sky
puisque nous avions déjà une
expérimentation sur l'éclairage public
c'est comme ça qu'on a rencontré
notamment au travers de l'incubateur de
51 divine le sky que la la start-up m2
ayem qui répondait parfaitement aux
critères de technologie et aussi de
réactivité
ça a été une collaboration excellente
6ème 2ième a été extrêmement réactif et
nous a permis de mettre en place ce
démonstrateur rapidement on a bénéficié
de cet environnement d'experts expert
sécurité et haïti pour pouvoir vraiment
améliorer notre système
c'est un succès technologique aussi on a
ainsi pu établir et construira une
solution d'éclairage intelligent
hautement sécurisé ça nous a permis de
gagner en maturité et de progresser d'un
point de vue sécurité avec la
multiplication des grands projets
d'infrastructures et des chantiers
d'intervention le groupe est né dix
rencontres des besoins de recrutement
dans la région ile de france ouest et
notamment dans les yvelines
le gestionnaire de réseau de
distribution électrique embauches
notamment des techniciens d'intervention
polyvalent c'est la séquence elle
recrute avec les bus
[Musique]
je m'appelle karine la guardia je suis
la déléguée ressources humaines de la
direction ene 10 en ile de france ouest
et actuellement nous recrutons des
emplois de techniciens d'intervention
polyvalente
cette activité consiste à venir dépanner
intervenir chez le client
assurer la maintenance et de
développement du réseau de distribution
d'électricité
vous avez des techniciens effectivement
qui peuvent remonter aux poteaux c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on dit et qui
peuvent réaliser des l'interventions
d'électricité l'entreprise est née 17
une suggestion aire de distribution
d'énergie aux services publics de
distribution d'énergie
c'est un c'est une entreprise qui offre
des perspectives professionnelles
importantes
vous pouvez très bien rentrer dans
l'entreprise en tant que technicien et
si vous êtes motivés si vous avez envie
d'évoluer
vous pouvez accéder à toutes sortes de
métiers on donne une offre de
professionnalisation et de formation
important
un technicien polyvalent dans son antre
et de poste il avoisine les 24000 euros
annuels en termes de rémunération brute
on recherche des jeunes diplômés
alors on vit des diplômes allant du ceap
et au bac + 5
les jeunes diplômés mais également on
peut aussi recruter des personnes qui
ont de l'expérience
pas forcément le diplôme est ce qu'on
recherche principalement ses des
salariés qui ont un bon savoir être qui
ont envie de s'investir dans des
missions de service public
une publions nos offres sur eni disque
recrute donc elles sont mises en ligne
il suffit donc de s'inscrire à être
candidate et bien un ordinateur
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile passer de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année et à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]